la piscine vu sous un autre angle c'est
l'expérience qu'ont pu faire les
participants à la marche découverte des
énergies urbaines à guyancourt
la visite du gymnase maurice bouquet et
du centre technique municipal était
également au programme marché avec ses
habitants pour découvrir la ville ça va
au-delà puisque c'est aussi dans une
politique de développement durable c'est
aussi dans une politique
environnementale pour faire découvrir
les qualités de des espaces dans la
ville
les énergies renouvelables sont des axes
primordiaux pour la ville
l'objectif de cette marche expliquer aux
habitants comment est géré la transition
technique des infrastructures en ce sens
là on va attaquer la troisième année de
remplacement des éclairages par du led
je voudrais que il voyait plus le
bâtiment comme ils le voyaient avant
c'est à dire que aller nager être en
forme
bien sûr tout à fait mais c'est aussi
voir ce que fait la ville aussi pour eux
l'aménagement durable mise en place
progressivement par la ville de
guyancourt n'avait jusque là jamais été
présentée au public à super parce que je
n'ai pas eu l'impression moi qui fais de
l'aquagym que tout le système c'était
tout ça en fait c'est bien de voir c'est
bien de voir comment commencer gérer
commencer s'est maintenu la mise en
place d énergie urbaine a pour vocation
de réduire les coûts
la piscine par exemple représente un
coût de 131000 euros par an pour la
ville
ces rendez vous éco responsables vont
être organisées tout au long de l'année
le prochain aura lieu au cours du mois
de mars